the Snowden character is fascinating
because he he lives in Russia now and
really not by choice because Russia was
the only country to grant him asylum
yeah Snowden's in Russia probably
grateful to have us on them somewhere
busily I only wanna be doesn't want to
be there I'm gonna be there which is
well let me address that too before
first of all if you don't know anything
about Snowden or don't know IV the the
movie the the man everything he did is
so quite fascinating it's such a complex
fascinating issue right now in our time
I really encourage you if not see the
movie start with the movie and then
there's other things out there it's
really quite an amazing story amazing
man regardless how you feel about what
he did yeah he's but as far as him being
in Russia where I'm sure he doesn't want
to be I can only tell you from
experience a lot of life is is doing and
being places you don't want to be I know
when I when I'm with my kids like on a
holiday with my wife and kids and we're
like stuck in traffic and it's just
miserable I encouraged our kids I make
them sing a song it goes like this it
says this is where we want to be well on
the beat well on a beat right and I find
that it helps to kind of turn things
around to embrace the situation like
right now it's easy for me to be like ah
I gotta do Conan today but it's easier
to be like this is where we
Oh to the line I guess we gotta Conan
this is where we want to be wanna beat
Andy I know you don't want to be here
come on everybody let's go
this is where we wanna be wanna be this
is where you're an awful guy but I do
love you
you